[Music]
you had a body double for your nude
scene this is something I'm always
curious about do you get to pick that
woman is that your decision and how does
it and how do you do it okay this was
the best shopping experience of my life
get him to pick my naked body double it
was like it was better than Amazon Prime
like we just got I will take one of
those yeah one of those and I mean my
husband was with me choosing them he was
like trying to act all professional I
think that I think that looks like you
that's that's good she looks she looks
very nice I was I got kind of creepy I
was like could I uh I want to see some
side boob can we can we get a picture of
her side here were the creep in that
scenario
Wow so do they so it's all photos you
don't look at picture I mean you look at
pictures you don't meet the person or
eventually meet the person on the set
but it's not like they come in and you
get you know yeah no I didn't get to
like examine the merchandise before I
what kind of question of my ass exactly
that was a fun look into my mind bring
your hair feels like me yeah that's
exactly how I feel as a woman you had a
bit of an issue because you and your
husband you wrote the script and then
you had to make this and you were very
conscientious about making sure that you
kept the cost down right and there was a
scene that required the use of a creepy
guy in the script yes that that is and
this this was a problem finding the
creepy guy is that right well we knew we
had to use local casting for that
because we didn't have the finances to
bring someone out from LA to Ohio where
we shooting and our director had said
just for background actors like keep an
eye out we want to make sure we're
populating the town with with people who
who really live here but for creepy guy
we were just gonna go with an actual
local casting you know through the
casting director but an actor but let's
be careful this is something that you
had to have kind of an intimate scene
yes so this the creepy guy was supposed
to have sex with me in a bathroom stall
right and we draw from life experiences
from what we write yeah
I let you borrow my experience for that
one thank you I appreciate that
so all of us so we're still looking for
for this actor and my husband calls me
from a Bob's Big Boy in Ohio I'm at the
production office I found our creepy guy
what do you mean he's like he's outside
he's sweeping the floor I don't even
think he works here but he's got a
wooden tune he's got a yellow shirt and
I think he's perfect I was like he's not
an actor like no no I got his AOL
address he's totally on board this is a
gentleman who needs to take your wife
from behind on camera we need a trained
professional for this but he was your
husband was willing to get a guy who's
wandering around a Bob's Big Boy with a
wooden - yes that's a nice partner you
have there in life I've been here
you